nagyon sokan megnézik páran kommentelnek
és ez így le és páran felszavaznak
kommenteket tehát hogy hogy nem nem
lehet hogy ő nem ír de beleolvas a el
így van egyébként az az érdekes hogy
nagyon nagyon fejlődik annak is a a
kultúrája hogy egyébként a kommenteket
is nagyon olvassák ez ez az vagány engem
is érdekel megnyugtat az hogy nem csak
én hallottam valamit abban a videóban
hanem tényleg ott volt és szinte egy
egyszer se kell csalódjak abba hogy ha
valamit én éreztem és elkezdek
beleolvasni sőt még a kommentekből
sokszor tanulok is vannak dolgok amiket
úgy meg se tudtam fogalmazni és akkor
egy-egy frapppáns megfogalmazás valaki
megpróbálja nagyon-nagyon frapppánsan
megfogalmazni hogy mi történt ott és
akkor ezren felszavazzák és rájövök arra
hogy tényleg igaza volt